i am mahira khan
Hey guys, hows it going? It's Justine
and continuing on the theme of old school unboxings
I just recently unboxed
This little guy, the original iPod
and today we are going to be unboxing
the iPhone 3G S
This is the third gen iphone in the series of iphones
and here it is!
In all of its sealed original packaged glory
My one main concern though is...
*unusual rattling sound*
what's that???
I've been kind of into unboxing the phones that I never
actually unboxed on youtube
on June 19, 2009 was when this phone was launched
and i have this little video of me in the apple store
the day that it launched in San fransisco
So, we're here in the Apple store and it's launch day
And, uh I ordered my phone online
I'm a little nervous though, because I really dont know what to expect
is it gonna be cracked, is it gonna be shattered, is this actually going to have been opened up
I mean this was a long time ago
the ebay listing said that it was factory sealed but do we believe it, I don't know
like this looks to be a little wear and tear right there
so the is the original IOS on this little guy was 3.0 and it last stopped supporting on February 21, 2014
and that was IOS version 6.1.6
it's model came in 8 ,16 and 32 (gigs). even until fairly recently 32 gigs is the least amount
that you were able to get in a current iPhone
and that was the most back then
Crazy!
okay, it really hurts to cut this package knowing how long it has stayed sealed
and what a sweet, sweet moment this is gonna be
lets do this
oh my...
(cutting noise)
(groaning)
it hurts so bad...
(plastic scrunching)
wow...
this is so old... its so old and no one has opened it, I don't know why...
so a few of the main selling points for the upgrade was a video camera, voice control and a digital compass
to be honest with you, I had to look it up because I didn't remember
Is it gonna be broken??
I've opened a lot of apple products before... and
this is not handy work, of an original box
unboxed iphone
I just wanna tell you, they would never! ever! Ever! do this
this is all scuffed up!
these people are liars
Apple would of never done this
ever, this is- this is a sham
this is a sham
like I just can't believe that apple would put something on like this
it doesn't, like it hardly even matches up, look
and this... it's like, look at this
yeah that's something apple would never do
so I think I got shiestered
like what was that, that was rattling around
this seems to be all there though , it was sealed very well and I clearly don't remember unboxing my 3Gs
I just know that's something that I don't think apple would have done
they usually have perfectly applied plastics, everything is like, to the T
I feel cheated and lied to
We've got our original stickers though, which is nice
This still says 3Gs so thats somthing
it's now gold but this looks like it has
fingerprints on it and they're not mine
I don't know what to think
anyway let's take a listen brochure if
there's something that you would like to
read just hit pause and then play again
look it
so cool
okay well I'm going to put this stuff
all back in here because well maybe I'll
sell it to somebody else
hey this definitely hasn't been opened
because this is something is very hard
to reproduce is this exact plastic it
has the Apple feel to it
this one right here what happened he was
different this is what I thought I heard
flying around you had to remember where
this was it's time to listen crowd
remover I'm pretty sure used to be in
here just say that's something what's
been responsibly Drive Safely reed
safety information check local logs
before youth interesting memories are
flooding back plugging it in take good
look at it so those smudges are mine but
basically this entire thing was pretty
flawless is it even goes if it doesn't
start off s to be such a disappointment
I definitely see something happening
what we want to sort know it's got to
got my signing up so maybe they let it
charge a little bit and then I'll come
back and give you an update an ageist
thing has been charging for a while the
back doesn't feel hot to the touch but
like you feel a little bit warmer than
it did previously like not warm there
was a lot of issues with the 3GS of the
back becoming a little bit too warm
where the battery is I don't think I
ever had that problem but I do remember
there were a bunch of issues like that
thankfully I didn't have it no service
yeah no kidding
there it is oh gosh look at that on lock
it's fine it's not even picking up my 5g
wireless signal
equal to join Network restore from
iCloud set up as a new phone
clearly I'm setting it up as a new phone
may take a few minutes to create your
new Apple ID okay so Kelly it's letting
me green Apple ID so I guess it worked
I'm going to not use iCloud I'm pretty
tired of that in a way that I'm going to
be able to make a phone call because
FaceTime based on audio calls wasn't a
thing look at this home button ah brings
up your search - oh my goodness my most
recent apps let's keep this old-school
YouTube button this was back in the day
when you should want is that oh my gosh
it's not only not even working like
these are the featured videos nothing is
there it doesn't even work
search receive search work doesn't work
at all nothing works here's the cam
there's no front facing camera photo
stream can I take a picture of like this
is how we used to take selfies one day I
just hope that it was in focus
wow it's as well so definitely a little
bit alive you guys can see it's not as
smooth as it is currently because hey
technology change this is only a 3
megapixel camera which is pretty crazy
this still looks pretty decent photos
see oh my gosh is it so slow I'm tapping
and nothing's happening there's the
Apple Campus it took us right there so
the old school maps look like maybe I'm
actually remember this phone do some of
you still have this phone I'm curious to
see what point in life you I started
getting iPhone routing the Apple sure I
mean is anything even going to happen
Austin you know worthy
why didn't be able to download these I
did not know the Katy Perry even had a
music video out
wow it is great well if people can gel
with an app would you like to get your
free copy of iBooks now I'm okay thank
you see if you can install Spotify holy
are you downloading wait the Apple ID
has not been used in the iTunes Store
iTunes let's see you're like I'm doing
some sort of like surgical procedure
right now and I'm just setting up an old
iPhone don't ever use iTunes anymore
okay that's it if you want it should
work I think it's gonna work this
application requires iowa 8.0 or later
you must update to iOS 8 to tell mode
and use this application
I just wanted to use Spotify on my old
baby boy phone then how might you do
anything I'm not going I'm not going to
be to do anything who thought this is a
good idea me anyway we'll look at our
calendar you look like old school
calendar it's a useless device I mean
here's the weather I can't use it to see
the weather I guess some people have you
know crazy collections of things this is
something that I choose to collect I
guess that's really it I'm going to find
it very very nice home for this on my
Apple shelf over there of old iPhones
and old gadgets I'm still trying to find
an old-school original iPhone I mean I
have one which is in pretty good
condition but I haven't been able to
start it up I don't know what's wrong
with it I really really really want to
find one that is in mint condition and
it hasn't been opened but they're very
very hard to find because most of the
ones that I've found are not the
original first-generation one so the
second gen and some of the ones that are
Christians are like $20,000 and at that
rate I might as well buy myself a new
car because that's just absurd
or maybe bicycle and then put some
freaking wheels on and say here's the
Apple car now let's do a little
comparison and show you guys what this
phone looks like compared to the
original iPhone to the new iPhone and to
one of the original iPod there are three
gs in comparison to the original
original iPhone
are pretty much the same exact size not
pretty much they are button locations
very very similar
3.5 millimeter jack power button that
SIM card slots all the same the irony is
that this is a jet-black iPhone
essentially here we have the 7 plus so
we just kind of put these together and
they're going to be smudgy I'm sorry
here's the iPhone that's seven plus this
is the newest iPhone and this is the 3GS
and basically kept black so when they
announce that that's something new which
have like I thought it really wasn't you
but they've already done it now make
them out with a jet white ceramic iPhone
let me tell you what I will definitely
be first in line for that one here's the
front those buttons are very very
similar they're still a circle yes
that's about it
hopefully on the next version of the
iPhone or not the next or the next next
version if there's on my iPhone 7s or if
there is a 7s or if it ends up being the
8 or 7 S which is a small upgrade and
then the age is actually a big upgrade
and those are all out at the same time
who knows rumor has it there won't be a
button which I would be totally fine
with something that's really cool on the
pixel phones which I've become quite a
huge fan of if they have the fingerprint
sensor on the back so if you're just
holding your phone and you go like that
you could unlock your phone iOS 6 1 is
now available for your iPhone that's the
latest version envisages that I kept in
that screenshot add contact create new
contacts all of the contacts Justine
so ok I sent myself a message if that
was delivered there it is sent today
what about the emojis little emojis look
like they're what emojis back then all
the little squares the ones that the
work always sweet baby so to use emojis
back in the day used to have to do and
the weird things
download all these separate apps
Japanese keyboards and then hit activate
it's quite the process you guys don't
know how well you have it unless you do
know how well you have it and you're
well aware so here they are this is the
family just quite strange little tip
dollar I had a much more nostalgic feel
for this one because I feel like as I
was unboxing both of these things I was
kind of feeling the same feeling that I
felt when I originally had them
so when I first got this one I was still
in high school I had absolutely no idea
what I was doing with my life I mean
does anybody ever actually really know
what they're doing with their life but
in high school you never really know and
things are always extremely confusing so
this thing for me
represented a time of extreme confusion
so IDs on the other hand I kind of
already knew what I was doing I was
still making youtube videos in 2009 and
I was still pretty well established
don't get me wrong not that well
established because I'm pretty sure I
was basically homeless in Los Angeles I
was bouncing back and forth between San
Francisco and LA not really sure where
my place was I knew that I was on the
right track and it was something that I
wanted to keep pursuing and I did
because I'm still here today still doing
it guess what yeah 2017 iJustine yes
she's still alive but I will say that as
you do go through life not knowing what
you're doing it can sometimes be a gift
because I feel like if I had a plan
especially in high school or even in
college I might not be doing what I'm
doing today because a lot of people told
me that what I was doing was crazy or
stupid or silly and I should probably
get a real job
I'll tell you what I work way harder at
my not-real job than I ever did working
for somebody else at a real job I've
said it before but making YouTube videos
especially for me because I still shoot
and it a lot of stuff myself it's a lot
of work it's a lot of time and right now
I'm probably the sample night and that
is this video so I can post it tomorrow
morning for you guys it is something
that I truly love and I'm seriously
honestly so passionate about technology
and everything that surrounds it I'm
pretty sure that that's something that
I've always known judging by my senior
picture that I took with my Apple
Computer that's one thing that I will
say that I've always stuck with is the
things that I'm passionate about I
somehow managed to work that into a
career and make that a part of my daily
life video games technology traveling
creating fun content making people laugh
aliy making some people laugh it's not
something that I get to do a lot and
very often and I could not choose a
better job so might be a little cheesy
and a little sentimental but I do have
Apple to thank for a lot of that feed
jobs aid me that inspiration at a super
young age I think I was in sixth grade
when I read my first book about Steve
Jobs and Steve Jobs as a per
and how he treated people sometimes
might not be the best but the thing that
I looked up most to perceive and the
words that stuck with me from a very
young age was think different because I
already was thinking differently and I
felt bad about it and I felt like I
should be doing what everybody else was
doing but from that sixth grade age
doing a book report on Steve Jobs that
nobody else having any idea who he was
at that point and just thought it was
some crazy computer girls and at that
young age Steve I will never forget the
way that you change in my life the way
that you have changed many many others
and happy belated birthday to the one
the only Steve Jobs we wish that you
were still here with us today because I
would love to see the way that you would
be pushing apples and what direction and
what would be happening right now
because I feel like the whole landscape
of everything could potentially be
different lift even still here all right
that was a lot of rambling but I'll see
you guys later thanks for listening and
don't be afraid to go after something
that you're passionate about because
it's your life you can't essentially do
what you want and even after this crazy
story that I just told you I don't want
you to think that any of this was easy
because my goodness it was it's been a
long freaking road of up and downs and
successes and many many failures but you
just don't quit that's the real secret
if you don't quit I mean that's like
eventually it's going to work out
that